on
184 km de sérénité à travers les forêts
et les prairies le long des ruisseaux et
au delà des hautes futaies c'est à ce
voyage que nous vous invitons le long du
sentier de grande randonnée sa route ce
truc partant de l'ouest nous passons par
l'os i'm pour atteindre le croisement de
keller steg à cette jonction nous
prendront la direction de trèves sur la
moselle le chemin des buts avec une vue
spectaculaire sur la fameuse boucle de
la sarre à horgen zh à ce niveau le
fleuve fait un demi-tour pour couler sur
quelques mètres en direction de sa
source
à rim la web et régine goergl parcours
le sentier sa route ce truc au moins
deux fois par an ouvert en 2007 il a
obtenu le label premium distinction
décernée au meilleur sentiers
d'allemagne par l'institut allemand de
la randonnée à rim l'arbre est à
l'origine de sa création il en connaît
les moindres tournant les moindres
rocher et il s'emploie à le faire aimer
du plus grand nombre
le chemin rocheux de shannon une des
premières étapes du sentier et pas des
moindres
brian moynihan
usa je tenais je n'avais vu pointer
le fournil de waltz par est une des
nombreuses surprises que réserve le
sentier une fois par mois c'est
pétulante boulangère animatrices se
réunissent ici et met la main à la pâte
sous l'oeil vigilant et amusé de marlyse
gorguet elle fabrique du pain au levain
comme autrefois qu'elles font cuire dans
le four à bois traditionnel à la fin de
la journée ce sont 80 mich qui sortent
du four
de quoi faire le bonheur de plus d'un
randonneur affamés
poursuivons le chemin en direction de
l'est
l'alpage de vendre il est l'endroit
parfait pour souffler un peu
on dirait qu'ici même les animaux sont
habités par la douceur de vivre sarroise
mais le grand air ça creuse au refuge de
l'alpage petter schumacher m a gâté les
randonneurs en leur servant des plats
régionaux et traditionnelles la poêle et
observe lasarrois est une de ses
spécialités le saucisson cuit et coupé
en petits morceaux puis petter le fait
revenir dans une poêle avec des pommes
de terre et des oignons
enfin il ajoute à la poêle et des
légumes frais de saison des produits
régionaux bien évidemment
je paye aussi envie
d'acheter une flash-mob guillaume rioux
n'a pas
trop mal on
adopte une
capote
vingtaine de
compagnies
nationales que vanguard of
iphone vêtements la halle berry à
l'euro d'honneur qui s'étend à traverser
uniquement des forêts des prairies sur
le sentier de sa route ce truc sera vite
détrompé le chemin finit toujours par
rejoindre l'eau comme ici au lac de l'os
i'm aux eaux cristallines
de la nature idyllique à l'odeur âcre du
charbon et du cambouis
meilleur guillorel ce membre du chemin
de fer historique de l'os heim est en
plein travail depuis près de 30 ans des
cheminots amateurs consacrent leur temps
libre à la restauration de vieilles
locomotives et d'anciens wagon
pour
outrage
attention au départ
certes la vieille dame de 80 ans n'est
pas très rapide mais quel bonheur de
s'offrir un petit voyage dans le temps
tout empreint de nostalgie
pour mettre en mouvement ce monstre
d'acier il faut tout de même quelques
compétences
des machines par grant a raccroché le
lie son bien à falun dafa
citoyens alors que l'équipe locale
fut
rachetée
pour les randonneurs fourbus c'est
l'occasion d'une escapade reposante et
original
le sentier continue jusqu'aux hautes
futaies des forêts de grands arbres
adultes
dominant la vallée de madrid la
forteresse de greensburg a des allures
de citadelle imprenable mais il en faut
plus pour nous décourager rendez-vous en
eau
le château médiéval de greensburg a été
construit il ya plus de 800 ans pour
défendre les terres des archevêques de
trêve
du haut de la tour de garde la
civilisation ans semblent bien éloignées
il en est de même ici dans la vallée
c'est cette quiétude cette nature
sauvage presque intacts qui fait la
particularité du sentier sa route ce
truc rien ne sembleraient pouvoir
troubler la tranquillité des lieux
ou presque juché sur son quad pétaradant
andreas luthe fixe se fraie un chemin
dans la forêt mais c'est pour la bonne
cause andreas est agent d'entretien des
chemins et des sites naturels tous les
jours il parcourt le sentier de
randonnée et veillent au grain panneaux
indicateurs itinéraire diversité des
paysages l'appellation de sentiers
premium demande une attention de tous
les instants
le petit pont qui traverse la rivière là
où je pars est une étape importante du
sentier ici le chemin se divise
les randonneurs doivent décider de
l'itinéraire à suivre direction morbach
et ida robert stein en passant par le
massif du hundsruck ou le long de la
moselle en direction de trèves c'est ce
trajet que nous allons emprunter
paysages immenses étendues lointaine le
sentier qui mène à travers les hauteurs
de bonheur at est un régal pour les yeux
à quelques kilomètres de là un site
façonner de la main de l'homme en
parfaite harmonie avec la nature le
barrage de la vallée de river rice la
réserve d'eau de toute la région de
trèves
aux premiers rayons du soleil les petits
lézards sortent de leur cachette et ils
ne sont pas les seuls à profiter de la
chaleur car nous voici arrivés dans la
vallée de l'arroux vers cette région
viticole n'est pas très grande mais son
vin est réputé et elle compte le plus
grand nombre de viticulteurs d'allemagne
ak zhol christophe fonelle browning est
toujours heureux d'accueillir les
visiteurs il est à la tête d'un vignoble
de tradition qui produit du vin depuis
sept générations
il mise sur des cépages classique le
riesling et le pinot gris
bright food products terry guillaume
c'est que je suis à neuf brisach la
souris comme la smart en passant
juste en face du chai se trouve le
paoline rohff un restaurant
gastronomique
benjamin feilles faire à 23 ans et il
est déjà un virtuose de la cuisine il
prépare ici un morceau de chevreuil dans
sa poudre de poireaux des génoises de
boudin noir de la purée de chou rouge et
des olives confites
le jeune chef et sans cesse en quête de
combinaisons gustatives inédites et
surprenantes parfois ses recettes lui
viennent en tête pendant son sommeil
quand ils ne rêvent pas à sa première
étoile c'est en effet l'objectif qu'il
s'est fixé et il s'emploie à s'en
rapprocher en déployant toute sa
créativité aux fourneaux
le paolino rohff ne propose pas
seulement une cuisine exceptionnelle
elle peut également s'enorgueillir de
compter parmi son personnel un oiseau
rare de la gastronomie un sommelier
fromage et
yogen fruz ce n'est pas un simple
amateur de fromage c'est un véritable
passionné
toutes les variétés inconnu qu'il offre
à déguster yogen schulz les a lui même
déniché en angleterre en france ou aux
pays-bas
d'accuser l'ipd femme de production
minimale faille note
de six gros ce musée sophie effectifs à
s'offrir fétiche rival manchester
garry that may cry cry cry et ma vie des
insectes en tasmanie la noix riches
nous voici bientôt arriver à trèves
cette ancienne cité romaine vieille de
plus de 2000 ans est un haut lieu
culturel et après un trajet de 120 km
elle est aussi le point d'arrivée de la
première variante de la boucle sa ruine
ce truc
nous décidons d'emprunter le deuxième
itinéraire du croisement de keller steak
jusqu'à idaho bernstein en passant par
le massif du hundsruck
dans la forêt près d'auxonne raul nous
retrouvons régime goergl et à rim lab
sur la colline du dol berg culminant à
695 m nous escaladons ce qui ne semble
être qu'un enchevêtrement de pierre et
pourtant ce sont les pièces d'un puzzle
archéologiques millénaire aux frontières
du hundsruck voici l'une des forteresses
celtes les plus imposantes d'europe
l'enceinte celtique de haute saône aux
vestiges d'un mur qui mesurait presque
20 mètres de hauteur et 25 mètres
d'épaisseur elle traverse la crête de la
colline sur deux kilomètres et demi
l'histoire de cette forteresse s'étant
d'environ 400 à 50 ans avant
jésus-christ
mon canal chaîne nbc nord et méditative
d'un grade tandis que d'en acheter
c'est sur nos toits déserts
le mur d'enceinte et nimbé de mystère
comment les celtes ont-ils vécu ici
quelle était la fonction de la
fortification
c'est ce que ces hommes s'emploie à
découvrir
presque tous les jours et par tous les
temps l'archéologue michael corps et ses
assistants fouillent le sol qui entoure
la fortification ils découvrent
régulièrement des morceaux degrés
pourtant inexistant dans la région une
trace de la présence romaine
même les plus petits détails comme ce
clou en bronze ont leur importance pour
les fouilles
agriculteurs
cachés dans les collines boisées du
hundsruck une surprise à soupçonner
attend le randonneur les papilles aux
aguets nous pénétrons dans le temple du
gourmet de newton
le chef étoilé oliver schaeffer est à
l'oeuvre
d'où de chevreuil au poivre taille
accompagné de sa purée de céleri
une poêlée de cèpes sauter
mais quand oliver schaeffer s'attelle à
la préparation de cd de gelée de pêche
caramélisées cela ne fait plus aucun
doute c'est bien un grand chef que nous
avons affaire
à la production
d'armes
lorsque le chef dresse une assiette il y
a une place pour chaque chose et chaque
chose est à sa place
porta au delà des mustangs à sa hausse
et une dégâts ce mot si je ferai une
manière aussi de muszyna ali puisque
nous sommes en droit de citation
l'escapade continue sur le sentier saron
ce truc en direction d' ida robert stein
bernd conrad et photographe animalier il
sillonne régulièrement à la vallée de la
tra web à la recherche de nouveaux
sujets
grâce à ces clichés ce photographe
amateur a pu faire son entrée dans la
très sélecte société allemande des
photographes naturalistes
berne conrad s'enthousiasme pour toutes
les créatures qu'il croise dans la
nature mais un animal en particulier a
sa préférence
l'aigle pêcheur chaque année lors de sa
migration vers le sud il vient faire une
halte près des bassins à truites de la
vallée de latrobe attirer par ses proies
faciles et en surnombre
berne conrad a passé plusieurs milliers
d'heures à l'observer afin de saisir les
images les plus spectaculaires de cet
oiseau de proie
les étangs à truites sont une étape
intéressante pas seulement pour l'aigle
pêcheur mais aussi pour d'autres
amateurs de poissons savoureux dans près
de 40 bassins petter hinsberger élèves
des truites arc-en-ciel des truites de
rivière et des ombles chevaliers selon
des méthodes biologiques et dans le
respect de la nature
cette
liste des
entreprises
qui reçoivent des vaches réseau laforêt
leurs
apps mc sont exhortés à
la place ou bakambu
l'exploitation possède même son propre
restaurant dans la cuisine le chef
alsacien pascal anthony prépare des
filets dont bhl et de truite saumonée il
les accompagne d'un ingrédient bien
particuliers provenant de sa région
d'origine la vitelotte une variété de
pommes de terre à la chair violette
il fait revenir les filets de truite
dans du beurre
puis il ajoute 17 frais et des légumes
de saison bio
pascal anthony m mélé la cuisine
française aux spécialités de la région
ce qu'il mitonne est un festin pour le
palais et pour les yeux
sur les collines du win ce truc est la
forêt s'étale comme un vaste tapis vert
vers morbach les passerelles de bois
mène les randonneurs à travers un
paysage singulier hortons brouch une
tourbière millénaire la biologiste
marguerittes scholtès et la gardienne de
ce biotope unique en son genre elle n'en
finit pas de s'émerveiller devant les 60
espèces de mousses présente dans la
tourbière certaines d'entre elles ont
des racines atteignant un mètre de long
notre
dans cette zone humide est la nature
celle de précieux trésors comme des
canneberges et des drosera
à quelques kilomètres de là la tour du
château de ville de bourges se dresse
sur son éperon rocheux pour atteindre le
château il faut gravir 80 marche mais
l'effort est largement récompensé par la
vue imprenable qu'offre le sommet de la
tour
dans le parc à gibier au pied du château
le ser montrait tous qu'il est le seul
maître des lieux
nous prenons à présent la direction
demeure sheed
ce tronçon est l'un des plus beaux et
des plus diversifiés du sentier sa route
ce truc son attraction principale et
l'anarchie de rebours une surprenante
maire de roche un désert de pierres
constitué de quartzite dutau luz est
vieux de plusieurs millions d'années
vu d'ici le paysage semble purement et
simplement infinie
non loin de là niché dans la vallée se
cache erstein un charmant village
médiéval au cours des 40 dernières
années et avec le souci du détail ses
habitants resteraient presque toutes les
maisons à colombages du centre
historique
au beau milieu du village dans une
ancienne grange dimière on peut déguster
des pâtisseries élaborées à partir de
recettes ancestrales
christ à schnyder propose à ses clients
d'aujourd'hui les traditions culinaires
de toujours par exemple le gratin aux
prunes
elle coupe les pruneaux 2 puis ajoute de
la farine de sagou tu y ait une espèce
de palmier du jus de pomme du sucre et
de la cannelle
ensuite elle recouvre les fruits de
pâtes
enfin elle parsème la préparation de
flocons d'avoine avant d'enfourner le
gratin
des
nomades seront mobilisés comme jamais
avec i'm on a boat et schnell hippique
est métallique tu me laisses vestiges
plastique est nomade sur le toit ou
maquereau vivra des fruits vraiment
frais a que quelques pas
et nous organisons
le graet on est servi avec une boule de
glace à la vanille et de la crème
fouettée
l'autre spécialité de la grange dîmière
c'est le gâteau orné d'une délicate
pierres fines en provenance de la ville
dida robert stein c'est ici dans ce haut
lieu de la pierre précieuse en allemagne
que s'achève notre escapade 284 km sur
le sentier sa route ce truc
le